Queridos amigos, amigas, fijaos en esta noticia
porque este vídeo tiene mucho que ver con
ella:
(Las sanciones amenazan la posición del Reino
Unido como patio de recreo para los oligarcas
rusos.
Las primeras sanciones contra los rusos [..] podrían
afectar a lo que algunos llaman el "Moscú
sobre el Támesis".
WSJ)
Pero antes de adentrarnos de lleno en este
asunto, os hago una pregunta: , ¿sabéis
cuántos millonarios hay en el mundo?
¿5 millones?
¿10 millones?
¿20 quizás?
Pues no, hablamos aproximadamente de más
de 50 millones de millonarios en todo el planeta.
Pero quizás el dato más impresionante es
que en la inmensa mayoría de los casos no
hablamos de herencias.
3 de cada 4 millonarios crearon su riqueza
con su trabajo.
Pero, ¿alguna vez te has preguntado dónde
prefieren vivir?
¿Cuáles son los destinos favoritos de las
personas más adineradas?
Bueno, seguro que ya sabéis por dónde van
los tiros.
Porque sí, la ciudad con más millonarios
de todo el mundo no es Nueva York, ni Singapur,
ni Dubai ni siquiera esa pequeña joya llamada
Miami.
¡Es Londres!
(La capital británica cuenta con unas 900
mil personas cuyos patrimonios netos superan
el millón de dólares.
Es decir, que si vais a Londres, aproximadamente
1 de cada 10 personas que veais por la calle
tienen más de un millón de dólares.
Y eso no es todo.
Londres también es la séptima ciudad del
mundo con más billonarios, los llamados mega-ricos.
En torno al támesis viven más de 60.)
¿Sorprendidos?
No me extraña, sobre todo cuando caemos en
que Londres no es una ciudad precisamente
famosa por el sol, las playas y los mojitos
al atardecer.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿Qué diablos tiene
Londres para atraer a tantos millonarios?
Vale la respuesta corta sería algo así como,
Alberto, es obvio: ¡Precisamente allí es
dónde está el dinero!
Y en cierto modo es verdad.
Londres es uno de los dos grandes centros
financieros a nivel mundial.
El otro, por cierto, es Nueva York.
Hablamos de una plaza donde confluyen inversores
procedentes de prácticamente todos los rincones
del mundo.
(Si eres un gobierno o una gran empresa y
quieres conseguir grandes cantidades de financiación,
seguramente te verás obligado a visitar la
capital británica.
Casi una quinta parte de todos los préstamos
bancarios internacionales y más del 12% de
todos los bonos internacionales cotizados
tienen su origen en el Reino Unido.
Además, Londres también es la capital mundial
de los derivados y el lugar donde se lleva
a cabo más del 40% de toda la negociación
mundial de divisas.
Hablamos de un enorme Hub de servicios financieros
de todo tipo que también acoge las sedes
europeas de centenares de multinacionales.
El llamado soft power, unos impuestos comedidos
y una regulación flexible y poco intrusiva
han situado a Londres en un epicentro mundial
de la actividad financiera.)
En otras palabras: Londres es un cohete de
hacer dinero.
Y a la gente con dinero le gustan los sitios
dónde puedan hacer todavía más dinero al
tiempo que consiguen mantener sus fortunas
seguras.
Vamos, creo que no estamos descubriendo la
pólvora…
Esto que os contamos tiene nombre y apellido:
Seguridad jurídica.
El ingrediente fundamental para que un país
prospere.
F
Pero, no nos desviemos.
Además de todos estos motivos que son la
clave que se esconde tras el éxito de Londres
y en general del Reino Unido, hay otro motivo
más que podemos destacar y que puede muchos
no conozcais: la llamada visa Tier 1, comúnmente conocida como visa
dorada.
Uuna idea quizás brillante pero
que como todo tiene luces y sombras.
Y que ahora ha sido señalada como una de
las vías de castigo contra Rusia por la invasión
de Ucrania.
O mejor dicho, como una de las vías de castigo
contra los oligarcas que respaldan a Vladimir
Putin.
Los legisladores de la UE impulsarán la prohibición
de nuevos "pasaportes dorados" y visados para
los rusos.
Reuters)
El Gobierno de Johnson acaba con los ‘visados
de oro’ para los oligarcas rusos.
El País)
(La represión del Reino Unido contra los
oligarcas rusos puede significar el final
de "Londongrad".
Las élites ricas se ven obligadas a "elegir
entre su riqueza, su lujo, su futuro y apoyar
a Vladimir Putin".
NBC News)
Amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os vamos a
contar cómo el Reino Unido se ha esforzado
en atraer millonarios procedentes de todos
los rincones del mundo y cómo esto se ha
convertido ahora en un enorme quebradero de
cabeza por culpa de las visas express concedidas
a cientos de oligarcas rusos.
¡Atentos!
[Por cierto, stop.
Un momento antes de continuar.
Si hablamos sobre las repercusiones de la
invasión de Ucrania, no podemos dejar de
hablar de energía.
Hace poco en VisualPolitik os contamos como
Azerbaiyán y sobre todo Turkemenistan podrían
llegar a convertirse a medio plazo en una
alternativa al gas de Rusia.
Pero claro, eso es algo que llevaría tiempo.
La cuestión es, ¿Qué podría hacer Europa
a corto plazo si Rusia decidiera cortar el
suministro de gas?
¿Es el GNL, el gas natural licuado, una alternativa
real?
¿Hasta qué punto podría suplir al gas ruso?
Pues bien, para conocer la respuesta a todas
estas preguntas no os perdáis el último
vídeo de Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal de
información financiera de Mutuactivos.
Os dejamos el link en la descripción.]
T1(LA VISA DE LOS RICOS)
Antes de nada, un apunte importante: las visas
doradas no son algo exclusivo del Reino Unido.
De hecho, hay 23 países en el mundo que tienen
visas de este tipo, cada uno con sus propias
peculiaridades.
(Incluso países como Grecia o España, que
no son precisamente conocidos por ser los
lugares más business friendly de la tierra,
cuentan con visas de este tipo ligadas a la
inversión en activos como inmuebles, acciones
o deuda pública.
Por ejemplo en España el modelo se implantó
en el año 2013 con el objetivo de dar salida
a muchos de los inmuebles vacios que quedaron
sin vender cuándo en 2008 comenzó a reventar
la burbuja inmobiliaria.
De esta forma, en España, puedes “comprar”
tu visa si adquieres inmuebles por valor de
al menos 500.000 euros.)
De hecho, tras el Brexit este se ha convertido
en un buen negocio para España y en general
los países mediterráneos.
Digamos que muchos británicos se están planteando
comprar propiedades para obtener una visa
y así poder hacer negocios y poder entrar
y salir de países como España sin más limitaciones.
(Británicos ahora eligen países de la UE
con visa dorada para recuperar sus derechos
de viaje - Schengenvisainfo)
Que es exactamente lo mismo que han hecho
también muchos rusos.
Solo hay que echar un vistazo a la Costa del
Sol.
Así que llegados hasta aquí, la pregunta
que muchos podéis haceros es, entonces, ¿por
qué centrarse únicamente en la visa dorada
del Reino Unido?
Pues, veréis, lo cierto es que pocos países
han tenido a la vez tanto éxito y tanta polémica
con este tipo de programas como el Reino Unido.
Desde su implantación en el año 2008 más
de 12.000 millonarios junto a sus familias,
han visto como las puertas del Reino Unido
se les abrían de par en par gracias a la
visa Tier 1.
(Actualmente y tras varias modificaciones
y endurecimiento de los requisitos, se necesitan
invertir al menos 2 millones de libras - algo
más de 2 millones y medio de dólares - en
compañías registradas en el país o en bonos.
Además, con este tipo de visa se puede optar
a la residencia permanente en un plazo determinado
de años que se acorta conforme crece la cantidad
de dinero invertida.)
Sí, en cierto modo es algo así como comprarte
una visa y “colarte” en la lista de solicitudes.
Esa es en esencia la idea.
Si traes dinero e inversión al Reino Unido
te abrimos las puertas de par en par.
La cuestión que podemos hacernos es qué
tipo de impacto tienen estos instrumentos
sobre la vida económica general.
Si esta visa Tier 1 es o no beneficiosa para
el país.
(S)
(Según defiende el propio gobierno británico,
el propósito de este tipo de visas es incrementar
la inversión y la capitalización de las
empresas registradas en el Reino Unido.
De esta forma la economía gana competitividad
y crece la generación de empleos.
Lo que también beneficia a las clases medias
y trabajadoras.
Cuantas más empresas haya y más robustas
sean estas mejor para todos.
De esta forma la visa dorada británica puede
ser considerada como todo un elemento dinamizador
para la economía.
Hablamos de un instrumento que ha logrado
atraer al Reino Unido decenas y decenas de
miles de millones de libras de inversión
productiva.)
Por supuesto este tipo de instrumentos también
tienen sus puntos débiles.
Muchos detractores las critican por ser una
especie de salvoconductos para grandes fortunas
cuya riqueza puede haber sido, digamos, obtenida
de forma poco “limpia” - por decir algo
- en países donde el estado de derecho y
los controles brillan por su ausencia.
Por otra parte también pueden actuar como
un refugio para muchas personas que consiguen
gracias a estas visas poder escapar de tiranos
de todo tipo.
Sea como sea, la cuestión que hoy más nos
atañe es otra: ¿Adivinais quienes han sido
los inversores más favorecidos por las visas
Tier 1 del Reino Unido?
3, 2,1….
¡Exacto!
Los chinos y los rusos.
Sobre todos los rusos.
Estos últimos de hecho han llegado a convertirse
en todo un quebradero de cabeza para Downing
Street.
¿Habéis escuchado hablar de Londongrado?
¡Atentos!
T2(WELCOME TO LONDONGRAD!)
En 2015 la cadena de televisión rusa STS
lanzó “Londongrad”
Una comedia de televisión sobre una agencia
especializada en solucionar problemas a los
millonarios rusos que viven en Londres.
Una trama que por muy random que nos parezca
en realidad no tiene nada de aleatoria.
Quizás ni siquiera sus historias sean del
todo descabelladas.
(De los aproximadamente 12.000 titulares de
visas doradas británicas, en torno a una
quinta parte son rusos.
Esto evidentemente tiene una explicación,
y para ello hay que remontarse al periodo
2008-2015.
Este fue un periodo conocido como “fe ciega”.
Entonces los requisitos del programa eran
menos y sobre todo apenas existían controles
para saber quienes eran realmente los beneficiarios
de las visas doradas y de dónde procedía
su fortuna.)
Y claro, si mezclamos en una misma coctelera
estos tres ingredientes: rusos, millonarios
y pocos controles, ¿qué nos sale?
¡Exacto!
Los Oligarcas.
De repente el modelo de visa Tier 1 británico
se convirtió en todo un imán para los oligarcas
rusos.
Tanto es así que en los siete años que transcurrieron
entre el 2008 y el 2015 se otorgaron el 85%
de todas las visas doradas a inversores rusos.
Pero claro, cuando se endurecieron los requisitos,
el flujo de llegada desde la Madre Patria
Rusia se ralentizó mucho.
Desde el 2015 los rusos ya “solo” suponen
el 15% de las visas concedidas.
Sigue siendo un porcentaje enorme pero ya
no es tan loco.
Seguro que no os sorprende.
Es como si a buena parte de los millonarios
rusos que buscaban invertir y poder vivir
en Reino Unido no les hiciera mucha gracia
que husmeasen en sus asuntos.
Seguro, seguro, no se porque, pero me da que
no os sorprende.
El caso es que hubo un momento en que el gobierno
británico se dio cuenta de que algo estaba
yendo mal, rematadamente mal, básicamente
porque el país se estaba llenando de oligarcas
amigos de Vladimir Putin.
Y con ellos también se estaba incrementando
el peso de las inversiones rusas ligadas al
gobierno del Kremlin en la economía británica.
Por ejemplo, según la organización Transparencia
Internacional desde 2016 más de 1.500 millones
de libras de activos inmobiliarios han sido
comprados en el país por altos funcionarios
y oligarcas rusos vinculados al Kremlin.
Y, lo cierto, es que la cifra real teniendo
en cuenta la opacidad con la que operan podría
ser muchísimo mayor.
Y por supuesto esto es tan solo un ejemplo.
Así que podéis creerme cuando os digo que
esto, desde el punto de vista geoestratégico,
no es la mejor idea del mundo.
Por no hablar de que muchas de estas personas
están acostumbradas a hacer y deshacer a
su antojo no solo sobre sus cosas sino también
sobre las de los demás.
Para ellos cosas como el estado de derecho,
la competencia o los negocios libres pues,
que queréis que os diga, suenan a imperfecciones
fruto de los blandengues occidentales.
Una cultura que tampoco es precisamente buena
para el clima general de los negocios.
Incluso existen informes que denuncian que
muchos de estos oligarcas han intentado influir
en la política británica, es decir, lo mismo
que hacen en la propia Rusia.
[Ya sabéis, cuestión de costumbres]
Así que en 2015, las autoridades británicas
comenzaron a cambiar y endurecer las condiciones
de acceso al tiempo que mejoraron los controles.
Incluso, se inició una investigación retroactiva
sobre más de 6.000 visas doradas.
Sí, no nos hemos equivocado, alrededor de
la mitad de todas las emitidas han sido o
están siendo revisadas y se está investigando
a sus titulares.
Ahí está por ejemplo el caso de Roman Abramovich
.
(M)
(Abramovich es un conocido oligarca ruso propietario
del club de fútbol Chelsea, que en 2018 retiró
la solicitud de renovación de esta visa porque
cada vez le estaban investigando más sus
negocios.
Al final optó por la ciudadanía israelí.
También tenemos el caso de Alexander Perepilichnyy,
un millonario ruso que entró a Reino Unido
a través de su esposa, y luego se le otorgó
una visa dorada a pesar de que en ese momento
estaba siendo investigado por la Interpol
por fraude, lavado de dinero y abuso de poder.)
Pero no solo podemos encontrar rusos en esa
polémica lista…
También tenemos a personajes como el indio
Nirav Modi, un millonario que está inmerso
en un proceso de extradición por lavado de
dinero y por supuestamente haber perpetrado
un fraude de 2.000 millones de dólares contra
el banco indio PNB.
O un montón de millonarios, políticos y
oligarcas kazajos, ucranianos e incluso bangladesíes.
Vamos, lo mejor de cada casa.
Todos ellos tienen en común haber recibido
su visa durante el periodo conocido como “Fe
ciega”.
Ahora bien, la persecución, la investigación
a los millonarios rusos en el Reino Unido
se ha vuelto aún más dura desde 2018.
¿Alguien recuerda qué sucedió en Reino
Unido ese año?
Fijaos.
(Rusos adinerados en Gran Bretaña se enfrentan
a nuevas medidas después de Salisbury - The
Guardian)
Exacto.
En 2018 es cuando se produjo el envenenamiento
del exespía ruso Serguéi Skripal y su hija,
envenenados con Novichok por dos agentes rusos.
El Novichok, para los que no lo sepais, es
un veneno ruso desarrollado en la era soviética.
Os dejamos, por cierto, en la descripción
un vídeo dónde os contamos todos los detalles
sobre cómo se emplea el veneno en la Rusia
moderna.
El caso es que el Reino Unido se dio cuenta
de que la presencia de oligarcas rusos próximos
al presidente Putin podía terminar convirtiéndose
incluso en todo un problema de seguridad nacional.
(El estatus de Londres como el patio de recreo
de oligarcas conectados al Kremlin socava
la postura dura del Reino Unido con Rusia
- Washington Post
Gran Bretaña no es el único país en el
que los oligarcas guardan dinero, ni los rusos
son los únicos que depositan dinero ilícito
en el extranjero.
Pero la crisis de Ucrania ha llevado al gobierno
británico a tratar de resolver las contradicciones
entre su política exterior y la escasa supervisión
de Londres.)
Reino Unido fue decidido a la hora de imponer
sanciones a Rusia, sin embargo, no fue tan
ágil con los oligarcas.
Esto es algo que incluso ha denunciado el
diario conservador The Times.
Fijaos.
C1(3 de marzo de 2022: El progreso dilatorio
del Reino Unido con las sanciones, empieza
a ser una fuente de vergüenza y un tema de
inquietud política".
Editorial del diario The Times)
Pensad que el dinero de los grandes oligarcas
rusos vinculados al Kremlin, ha enriquecido,
entre otros muchos, a bufetes de abogados,
banqueros, arquitectos y empresarios de la
hostelería y el sector del lujo.
Auténtica dopamina económica que ralentiza
la toma de decisiones difíciles.
Sea como sea, está claro que esta vez todo
es diferente.
Y que el paraíso británico y en general
europeo para las grandes fortunas rusas puede
estar llegando a su fin.
("No hay lugar para el dinero sucio en el
Reino Unido...
se ha avisado a los que respaldan a Putin:
no habrá ningún lugar donde ocultar sus
ganancias mal habidas" Boris Johnson, Primer
Ministro del Reino Unido)
Pero, llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti.
¿Crees que un sistema de visa dorada sería
beneficioso para tu país?
¿Debería filtrarse a los beneficiarios o
por contra deberían estar abiertos a cualquier
inversor?
Déjanos tu opinión aquí debajo, en los
comentarios.
Y ahora si te ha gustado este vídeo no olvides
darle like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik,
así como darle a la campanita para recibir
una notificación y no perderte ninguno de
nuestros vídeos.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.